اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من غلاف غزه اهلا
بكم كتائب القسام تقول انها قتلت وجرحت
افراد اربع مجموعات اسرائيليه راجيه
واستهدفت ست دبابات من طراز ميركافا ومروح
وناقله جند وجراف في معارك خان يونس
ووسائل اعلام اسرائيليه تكشف عن اصابه
قائدي كتيبتين في المعارك بعد اعلان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اصابه 15 عسكريا في معارك
غزه شهداء وجرحى جراء قصف مدفعي وجوي
متواصل على خانيونس والمناطق الشرقيه
للمنطقه الوسطى ووزاره الصحه في غزه تقول
ان الاحتلال ارتكب 12 مجزره خلال 24 ساعه
راح ضحيتها
10035 شهيدا وتحذر من انتشار الاوبئه بين
النازحين والسكان وتقول ان البنيه التحتيه
في رفع هشه ولا يمكنها تحمل احتياجات
السكان والنازحين
اشتباكات وانفجارات متواصله في مخيم
الفارع جنوب طوباس في الضفه الغربيه
واصابه فلسطيني برصاص الاحتلال خلال
اقتحام المخيم واستشهاد اربعه فلسطينيين
بينهم ثلاثه في تبادل اطلاق نار
بمستوطنة انصار الله الحوثيين يقول
للجزيره ان رد الجماعه سيكون قريبا وقويا
وان القاعده التي استهدفها الامريكيون
كانت خارج الخدمه الى
اللقاء